dunk on these
losers get
them
M merko on a two-hour Cat Williams rant
about other
podcasters man he's all sucking their
dicks and [__] [__] they all
sucking Weinstein's dick and [__]
PewDiePie couldn't get two views before
before his stupid Call of Duty
videos who is this Ethan Klein why is
all these Jews why Keem gotta be what
that
hiding old old [__] lawn gnome
looking
ass I'm telling you I think the Paul
brothers are
[__] I don't I think that fish tack
fish tank is [__] whack
dog having C Williams go off on the
internet would be very
funny Shane Dawson made two movies and
you can't find them on Netflix or to
be little ass sticking his dick in cats
and buying little boys and
[Laughter]
[__] oh [__] that was so okay come on
um timpool starts a new station right
after Philip the Franco I see you Timo
tempool be clinging to the fence harder
than Dave Ruben's hair
plugs and I seen what's under the Hat I
seen what's under the Hat it's an
eye these having conversations about
conversations oh
[__] okay guys we're done all
right conversations about
conversations not playing anymore this
mic this n Maddox won't drop it even
though dick masteron dumped his ass 10
years ago Eric July afraid of a little 5
foot two who puts poits on his
window I thought you were a gangster you
said pull
up what what do these know about comic
[Laughter]
books you can't find his comic books on
Amazon or
Kindle ain't no one ain't no one
adapting his comic books to anime you
ain't finding that [__] on crunchy roll
or
2B or
2B what is this in the comic books got
to do with the International School of
ministry
[Laughter]
anyway oh [__] okay move off from the
mic thing someone says merch will adopt
cat yes oh not that
cat hey it's forat merch did you go
shopping ain't no [__] liquor
in his
house you said you was going to get
raisin brand when you went to the store
during night where you see cat just
walking behind him with a
robe like wow and I thought Marge was
annoying in the background hey hey
[__] put put that glass down on
the table so I can knock it off onto the
floor he's doing cat [__] around the
house like
actually oh [__] get off the countertops
oh
[__] get off the countertops you know I
can't reach the top cabinet unless I'm
on the
countertop literal Cat
Williams could somebody draw cat
Willams
just a little pimp cat I might actually
do that for the bad luck boys I might
ask [__] taper to make or top lopster
to make like a [__] like Clarence
dressed as Cat Williams yeah just
Clarence call it Cat
Williams just put a little put a little
pimp suit on
Clarence he's tiny and black it
fits